bonjour david lisnard où je remercie de
nous rejoindre des tno santé politique
ce matin vers l'est républicain de cale
président de l'association des maires de
france soutenait valérie pécresse dans
cette campagne et vous êtes avec nous
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour cristal bertron
bonjour aujourd'hui bonjour creissels du
groupe la dépêche david lisnard vous
avez dit sonné hier les candidats à la
présidentielle on va évidemment parler
dans quelques instants mais d'abord
l'actualité situation sous tension
encore depuis une dizaine de jours
depuis l'agression divan colonnes en
prison gérald darmanin seront sur l'île
aujourd'hui dans une interview à
corse-matin ce matin il se dit prêt à
aller jusqu'à l'autonomie en dix ans la
question est de savoir ce qu'est cette
autonomie qu'est ce que vous pensez de
ces déclarations du ministre l'intérieur
la question de l'autonomie c'est une
vraie question ça veut pas dire
indépendance et moi je suis un ardent
partisan de la décentralisation et même
de la subsidiarité donc qu'il y ait
encore une évolution statutaire en corse
le président la république avait dit
tout le contraire il n'ya pas longtemps
il ya trois ans mais bon on est habitué
à cela ça me fait pas peur en revanche
annoncer cela en donnant l'impression
src pas donner l'impression en donnant
raison à la violence à nouveau éminent
confrère parler sur un tweet ce matin de
prime à la casse je trouve ça
complètement irresponsable d'une part
c'est à dire que ça pose deux questions
d'abord dans une négociation si vous
lâchez tout avant d'arriver ce n'est pas
la peine d'y aller premièrement
deuxièmement ça veut dire que la
négociation se fait au prisme des
aspirations des plus violents des
éléments qui ont pourri toutes les
manifestations s'étaient organisés hier
soir je discutais avec le président des
maires de haute corse qui est le mien
cisco qui est un homme droit que il
accepterait je qualifie de modérés de
centre-gauche il me disait à quel point
ils étaient outrés par la façon dont
finalement donné raison à une minorité
ultra violente parce que le peuple corse
que veut-il c'est ça la vraie question
qu'il faut se poser alors que depuis le
continent on a une vision totalement
caricatural et fosses de la corse mais
l'exécutif par cette facilité
cette volonté d'apaisement pré
électorale mais soit on rétablissait
lors tout de suite c'est ce qu'il
fallait faire soit on met une stratégie
négociations mais venir cédé sous la
pression d'une minorité agissante c'est
extrêmement grave souvenez-vous des
outre mer et de la guadeloupe ce concept
d'autonomie voire d'indépendance avait
même été évoqué par sébastien lecornu au
moment où lille était totalement à feu
et à sang c'est des questions qui sont
sérieuses mais qui ne peuvent pas être
soumises à la violence et à vous le
voyez comme un cadeau électoral approche
de l'élection présidentielle je pense
que
tout est fait
pour que le pays reste dans l'atonie
civique jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle dans tous les domaines je
crois qu'après l'élection présidentielle
et législatives
quel que soit d'ailleurs le candidat élu
ou la candidate élue et un certain
nombre de bombes à retardement qui nous
mettront face aux réalités le déficit
public déficit de l'état qui augmente
depuis 2018 alors qu'il baissait depuis
la grève la fin de la crise des
subprimes la perte de compétitivité du
pays par le commerce extérieur et les
promesses aille trop loin en corse
justement parce qu'il ya une espèce de
pression électorale mais je crains qu'on
dise n'importe quoi pour qu'on ne parle
plus du problème corse jusqu'aux
élections mais qu'on soit dans une
spirale qui crée des frustrations et la
difficulté si vous vous laissez ces
circonstances sont difficiles et même
pour nous parce qu'on a envie de
soutenir l'état et l'exécutif pour que
la paix revienne si vous vous laissez
c'est comme pendant la guerre on en
est
lui à plusieurs reprises il ya trois
députés sur quatre sur autonomy
il est vous l'avez dit les
revendications n'ont pas été entendus
jusqu'à là je crois que en fait ils
légitimise la violence tout simplement
donc par symétrie par miroir une
délégitimise les élus mais
gérald darmanin tout autre sujet mais
puisqu'on en parle il a annoncé hier
qu'il renonçait à fermer deux mosquées
dans votre ville de cannes alors qu'il
avait annoncé en la justifiant par des
propos antisémites qu'est ce que vous
pensez être survient alors je connais
bien cette situation c'est la plus
ancienne mosquée de cannes qui est là
depuis une trentaine d'années et la
ville de cannes avait alerté sur des
éléments très prestigieux avait transmis
à différentes autorités du ministère de
l'intérieur procureur et c'est sur des
propos qui avaient été tenus non
seulement antisémite mais également
homophobes
d'appel à la violence et et qui
manifestait une radicalisation en tout
cas des propos qui étaient clairement
anti républicain anti france tout
simplement mais là le problème c'est que
la procédure qui a été retenu par l'état
moi je la soutenait je soutiens d'état
dans ces cas là enfin comprenez c'est
toujours ce c'est ce conflit de deux
entre l'éthique de responsabilité et
l'éthique de conviction mais
le problème c'est que la procédure qui a
été engagée c'est ce qu'on a découvert
après a été faite en application de la
loi sur le séparatisme mais sur des
faits qui avait été révélé qu'ils
étaient antérieurs à la loi on apprend
en première année de droit que le que la
loi n'est pas rétroactive donc il y
avait une impasse les dirigeants de la
mosquée ont changé ils ont apporté des
garanties et donc je pense que l'état
était dans une impasse et ne pouvait pas
prendre d'autre décision au risque
d'avoir un camouflé juridique et et
finalement la solution qui a été trouvée
la bonne parce que l'immense majorité
des pratiquants de cette mosquée sont
des gens très bien
et qui est laid et dirigeants ont changé
ils ont enlevé l'ancien dirigeant qui
posait problème ils ont supprimé les les
comptes de ce dirigeant et il faudrait
être très très vigilant mais la mairie
aidera le ministre de l'intérieur est
très vigilant sur ce dossier
ouidah vinista vous êtes rendu en
ukraine avec votre équipe c'est un
déplacement à hauts risques
pour quelle raison est ce que vous avez
souhaité vous rendre là bas d'abord
parce qu'il faut toujours voir sur place
les choses pour
être en situation de crise pour être
efficace alors mon équipe était resté en
pologne il est hors de question d'amener
des collaborateurs dans un dans une zone
potentiellement à risque évidemment et
il ya ensuite donc j'ai fait un périple
dans un pays que je connaissais bien où
j'étais allé presque une vingtaine de
fois déjà 800 kilos mais doris à peu
près où un peu plus même donc en alors
elles vivent puis ivan offrant six qui
avaient au sud-est puis un peu plus à
l'est et en rentrant est d'abord ça a
permis de fiabiliser des contacts sur
place pour acheminer une aide
humanitaire qu'on apporte depuis cannes
directement puisqu'on en est à treize
convoi qui vont directement en ukraine
pour une raison simple c'est que la
présidente de france ukraine via khan
younis sport à l'ukrainienne assez
important donc on a des contacts très
fiable y compris pour les fixeurs à la
frontière et donc d'adapter d'ajuster
l'aide humanitaire deuxièmement avec
l'association des maires de france nous
avions été pionnier en appelant à la
solidarité pour l'accueil de réfugiés
parce que j'ai vu tout de suite la
gravité de la situation et en
l'organisant que la protection civile ce
grand convoi qui nous a permis de
récolter 2000 tonnes de matériel de
première nécessité et donc les contacts
fiabiliser les choses être sûr que le
dernier kilomètre et fiables en termes
d'aidé humanitaire mais aussi le premier
kilomètre pour le départ des réfugiés
est ce que j'ai vu là bas c'est que
toutes les écoles sont fermées dans tout
le pays y compris dans les zones qui
étaient pas encore en guerre et que
toutes les classes d'école tous les
lieux publics les théâtre accueille des
réfugiés qui sont des femmes et des
enfants par dizaines voire centaines de
milliers souhaite partir mais pour ainsi
en fait des zones noires ce qui est très
ce qui était frappant d'abord c'est la
dignité de ce peuple dans cette tragédie
ça saute aux yeux c'est à dire que j'ai
vu des trains bondés des gamins dans des
portes bagages et donc il ya un peu de
pour entrer dans la phase aimé mais ça
reste très très digne quoi c'est très
impressionnant et donc lune
la difficulté c'est de sécuriser ces
personnes là qui pensent qu'elles vont
revenir très vite en fait pourquoi par
tél pour protéger les enfants mais ne
pour ne pas en encombrant si je puis
dire gêné les maris qui sont au combat
il ya une combativité une
gravité dans dans la situation qui est
manifeste et ces personnes veulent
veulent revenir très vite mais la
réalité c'est qu'elles ne reviendront
pas très vite et c'est là que j'en ai
parlé mariage a pas qui est qui qui a
été très réceptive je tiens à le dire
puisque on doit refaire un point mais il
faut qu'on aille vite maintenant il faut
qu'on prenne le plus en amont possible
les réfugiés l'ukrainien parce que plus
on attend plus on crée des situations
d'insécurité juridique pour des enfants
il ya des réseaux tout vous éloignez
l'ukraine vers la sauve équivalent à la
pologne j'ai vu que vous avez des
passeurs qui font passer des réfugiés
d'autres pays par la pologne etc et plus
vous avez qui viennent pour des raisons
compréhensibles enfin qui sont pas des
réfugiés ukrainien avec un canot c'est
le contrôle
c'est à dire que les polonais
aujourd'hui sont très seuls ce que vous
voyez à cracovie ce que vous voyez à
varsovie ce que vous voyez dans ce
centre commercial qui est à quatre
kilomètres du poste frontière où il ya
3000 réfugiés dans un centre commercial
l'ailé les autorités polonaises sont
très seuls seule la grande-bretagne à
une pièce où il faut remplir des papiers
etc ils choisissent leur immigration
ukrainienne donc il faut qu'on fasse
pareil qu'on aide ces personnes il faut
on peut pas se contenter de voilà deux
postures cessé de lui même christian
estrosi dit que les alpes-maritimes sont
débordés par l'afflux de réfugiés
aujourd'hui
craignant c'est le cas et comment est ce
qu'il faudrait gérer ça il ya deux
grandes zones géographiques en france
qui accueille beaucoup de réfugiés au
kenya paris et la région parisienne et
il ya les alpes-maritimes d'abord parce
que son nom
est et parce qu'une solidarité d'une
diaspora ukrainienne qui étaient déjà
présentes d'une diaspora russe il faut
le dire qui et ray allen dimension
interne à une perception internationale
et les très pauvres d'ukrainiens mais on
doit faire face et on est en train de
trouver les solutions or il est vrai
qu'on a la côte d'azur a toujours été
une terre et je pense à cannes notamment
une terre de l'exil moi je me suis alors
j'étais gamin c'était les iraniens ont
accueilli à cannes on a eu les liban et
récemment des irakiens des syriens ont
accueilli des familles de syriens sauf
que là c'est puissant quand italiens
soient mieux réparties sur le territoire
c'est maintenant on va se coordonner
avec l'état mais en tout cas on ne peut
pas d'argent pas le cas mais
toujours pas de coordination il ya un
travail qui était mis en place puisque
j'avais demandé à ce qu'on intègre la
cellule interministérielle de claquer de
crise mais et qu'il a été décidé pour
des raisons je comprends que au greffe
et une autre organisation à cette
cellule interministérielle avec la mf
non par une chape a été très réceptive
maintenant il faut qu'on passe aux actes
est pour l'instant et chaque heure
compte mais auquel vous dire que dans
les alpes-maritimes va beaucoup de
solidarité chez les habitants pour
accueillir les écrivains dont moi je
suis très fier qu'on accueille tous et
ukrainiens comme à chaque fois qu'on a
su accueillir des gens persécutés et on
va faire face j'avais proposé vous avez
mis à disposition des salles municipales
et salles municipales de l'hébergement
des traducteurs on accueille les enfants
dans les clubs de sport dans les écoles
on a mis en place bien sûr de
l'accompagnement psychologique et j'ai
même mis à cannes une sorte de cellule
consulaire j'ai un renvoi de
l'ambassadeur d'ukraine encore tout à
l'heure on doit l'état sera débordé
comme à chaque fois donc mettons en
place les outils pour délivrer les
papiers mais plus on identifie en amont
et je termine tard donnez moi les
réfugiés j'ai vu comment ça se passe à
la frontière les gens attendent 30
heures 49 50 heures et on leur donne un
papier très fiable parce que les
polonais font bien le boulot et une fois
qu'on a ce papier là on devrait tout de
suite pouvoir les ramener les communes
sont prêtes à envoyer des bus le font
spontanément et les accueillir vous
assure qu'on arrivera à relever ce défi
alors voilà de la question des réfugiés
vous avez réclamé un embargo total sur
le gaz russe certains pays européens ne
veulent pas notamment les allemands est
ce que ça veut dire qu'il faut se
désolidariser de l'union européenne
alors qu'emmanuel macron dit l'important
c'est de s'afficher unie face à vladimir
poutine
l'important c'est d'être efficace et
c'est d'avoir des résultats alors j'ai
pas appeler un embargo chikhi d'ailleurs
pour rappeler à ça j'ai répondu à
nouveau confrère moi qui me poser la
question sur le gaz ce qui relativise
la portée de mon propos bon voilà je
peux
être conscient de ses propres limites
mais ceci étant il est évident puisque
emmanuel macron préside l'union
européenne il s'est enfin il a il il
pose même un beau coup donc en
l'occurrence on doit être en mesure de
sortir des
déclarations grandiloquentes et avoir
des actes quand vous nous parle de
défense européenne et on apprend que
l'allemagne achète les des f-35 aux
américains on nous parle de solidarité
européenne et on voit qu'il ya aucune
organisation européenne pour l'accueil
des réfugiés on nous parle de
performances européennes et on voit
qu'on est incapable incapable d'être
solide vis-à-vis de la russie sur
l'achat de gaz il est scandaleux qu'on
continue d'acheter du gaz qui alimente
l'armée russe les russes c'est un grand
pays la russie il faudra qu'on sache
proposer un partenariat avec la russie
on est venu en espérant qu' elle soit en
vie démocratique mais évidemment c'est
le rôle de la diplomatie toujours de
chercher cela mais vous pouvez le faire
que si vous êtes dans un rapport de
force la russie a fortiori avec vladimir
poutine ne comprend que le rapport de
force nous avons les moyens d'avoir de
la force notamment sur l'énergie vous
savez il ya un dispositif de solidarité
sur le gaz c'est à dire que si l'union
européenne si l'allemagne qui est qui a
cédé aux écologistes et s'est mise dans
les impasses énergétique en renonçant au
nucléaire ce qu'avait décidé le
président la république il ya trois ans
aussi en annonçant la fermeture de 14
réacteurs aujourd'hui en annonçant
il a quand même commencé on à fermer
fessenheim et puis on a perdu dix ans et
aujourd'hui dit on découvre que le
nucléaire est décarbonée et qui nous
rend souvent
chacun peut se tromper c'est seller en
même temps tisme qui veut ça mais
sur sur la réalité c'est que vous savez
que si l'allemagne 16 d'acheter du gaz
il ya un système de solidarité européen
qui existent pour mutualiser précisément
le coût de cette décision les américains
les américains ne peuvent pas se
désintéresser de ce qui se passe en
europe il peut pas se contenter de
vendre des armes et et d'asseoir
l'autorité de l'otan il avoue trouver
quelqu'un mais je pense que jamais on
pourrait dire si l'allemagne et les pays
européens cessent d'acheter du gaz nous
leur vendons du gaz à un prix de
compétitif parce que ne pas skier un
contexte de guerre et que la
géopolitique nécessite puisqu'on ne veut
pas être dans l'engrenage de la guerre
face à la russie et on a raison et bien
qu'on utilise les armes économiques au
maximum y compris celles énergétique un
mot sur les conséquences pour les
français et notamment sur leur
porte-monnaie de cette guerre en ukraine
notamment sur la hausse des prix la
hausse des prix du carburant jean castex
à proposer une remise de 15 centimes
parmi tes doit présenter un plan de
résilience cet après midi est ce que
pour vous résultat 15 centimes sont
suffisants ou est ce qu'il faut faire
prises notamment par l'état et heureux
sir que
je pense que vous comprenez bien que
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
fait des rentrées fiscales dont on a
tellement besoin donc plutôt que de
sortir sans arrêt des chéquiers qui
entretiennent cette infantilisation d'un
exécutif qui serait parfois gentil
parfois mes chambres moi c'est quelque
chose je ne supporte plus ciblées et
donc la problématique il ya évidemment
structurellement la problématique de
notre indépendance énergétique et dans
l'immédiateté la nécessité de trouver
des dispositifs
fiscaux fiscaux pour que les personnes
qui ont besoin de l'enfant quand vous
gagnez les 200 milles 320 oui évidemment
ce serait bien mais ce n'est pas la
bonne manière sauf que pourquoi baisser
les taxes ne le font-ils pas parce que
politiquement c'est beaucoup moins
visible que de distribuer de l'argent
que l'on n'a pas puisque l'état est
surendetté vous comprenez cirque eu un
système de baisses de taxes faire un
chèque ça entretient cette
infantilisation et on est dans un
système pré électorale donc c'est open
bar enfin vous le voyez sur l'évolution
du point de l'indicent la fonction
publique où on le voit sur la
multiplication des dépenses les dépenses
de l'état hors qu'ovide ont augmenté de
40 milliards d'euros ces dernières
années orco vide comment le noeud
gordien dans lequel nous sommes c'est
celui d'un pays qui a le record des
prélèvements obligatoires impôts et
charges quel record du monde de la
dépense publique et qui a de moins en
moins de services publics de proximité
avec des fonctionnaires souvent mal
payés donc que se passe-t-il entre cet
excès de prélèvement et cette difficulté
c'est la désorganisation de l'appareil
public dont personne ne parle c'est
c'est le coeur de l'action pourquoi un
détenu corse assassins de préfet il faut
jamais l'oublier mais enfin se fait
tabasser par un islamiste mais c'est le
quotidien des prisons dans le pays qui
prélève le plus d'impôts
voilà nous sommes dans une situation
grave la france va rebondir est un grand
pays mais nous pouvons pas faire
l'économie d'une réflexion profonde sur
l'organisation de l'appareil d'état vous
parlez des fonctionnaires le dégel du
point d'indicé est une bonne mesure pour
vous c'est une mesure qu'on nous
annonçait il ya trois mois comme étant
complètement démagogique en deux ans la
justifier sur l'inflation l'inflation ça
fait des mois que j'en parle elle est là
il ya d'autres façon de rémunérer les
fonctionnaires et face à l'inflation que
le dégel indice du point il ya des
primes il ya le gvt il ya plein de
dispositifs donc comment cette mesure
qui était qualifié de démagogiques
devient tout à coup pertinente c'est
c'est vraiment il faut poser la question
c'est pas à moi à parler ce qui s'est
passé hier puisqu'il ya vous avez reçue
avec l'assemblée des départements de
france et régions de france les
candidats à la présidentielle vous avez
dit que c'était le moment de débat le
plus puissant depuis le début de la
présidentielle pourtant il y avait un
absent emmanuel macron un deuxième eric
zemmour va en parler mais un accent
emmanuel macron comment vous avez
interprété cette absence du chef du
candidat j'ai dit que c'était le débat
le plus puissant d'abord parce qu'on
était content de ce qu'on avait fait et
puis parce qu'il y en avait pas eu
tellement d'autres avant aussi mais mais
c'est vrai il est vrai qu'hier ce qu'on
a vu avant je vous parlais de l'absent
vous parlez des présents on a eu dix
candidats qui sont venus qui avaient
tous le même temps de parole y avait pas
de piège on voulait qu'il soit à l'aise
mais on est allé dans le fond on a vu
parfois des contradictions de certaines
propositions mais c'était très
respectueux tous les candidats l'ont
reconnu et je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on arrive à faire c'est de la
contreverse civile c'est à dire des
débats forts or sur le fond et
respectueux sur la forme c'est souvent
le contraire de ce que l'on constate
vous je pense que vous le constatez
commenceriez de la vacuité des effets
d'annoncé des petites punchline et puis
on travaille pas le fond sur les absents
il ya eu deux absents eric zemmour a
annulé sa présence lundi soir et
il a été gelée je vais relancer après
vous cacher parce que j'ai été surpris
et il m'a pas répondu tout de suite il
m'a envoyé un sms hier soir pour dire
que et qu'il présentait ses excuses qui
lui un problème d'agenda kim qui plus
est
jeu et ensuite les manuels maquereau en
blanc ce que j'ai considéré que c'est
une forme de mépris vis-à-vis des élus
et des territoires coûte écoutez je ne
veux pas tomber dans cette facilité la
circulaire qu'on vient vers nous quand
il ya la crise et gilet jaune
que quand il faut faire des
vaccinodromes appris mardi qu'il fallait
pas en faire et puis tout d'un coup il y
avait une désorganisation totale
la nfl est vraiment transpartisane hier
ski ski on a chacun nos convictions vous
entendez andré laignel c'est un opposant
c'est que chacun ses nuances mais
l'institution et les trans partisane et
tous les candidats étaient accueillis de
la même façon c'est vraiment c'était un
magnifique exercice démocratique et
c'est la force de l'association des
maires de france avec régions de france
et départements de france qui était
partenaire
c'est ce que c'est ce qui ressortait oui
ce qui m'a frappé hier c'est que les
deux élus qui ne sont pas venus fallait
deux élus parce que les méthodes qui ne
sont pas venus sont les deux seuls qui
n'ont jamais eu de mandat local et ce
sont peut-être les plus centralisateur
je pense que c'est peut-être les plus
bonapartiste finalement quand même un
symbole wen en tout cas en tout cas j'y
vois une signification une signification
politique et alors que toutes les
garanties été apportées pour que cela se
passe bien c'était dix minutes de libre
d'expression puis 20 minutes de
questions c'était une demi heure dans
l'agenda d'une journée mais je pense que
manuel macron a un problème avec les
pouvoirs indépendants quand on l'a
constaté pendant tout le quinquennat
vous vous le coup fait une bonne
conclusion sur la méthode du prochain
président avec les élus locaux
évidemment vous en attendez beaucoup
valérie pécresse par exemple elle a
composé une grande conférence des
territoires quand on voit ce qu'a donné
la précédente c'est vraiment une bonne
méthode c'est une bonne méthode si
les intentions scène cette conférence
sont bonnes on peut lui c'est une bonne
méthode évidemment si la crise et pour
préparer la réforme fiscale dont on a
besoin pour recréer la responsabilité de
la liberté pour remettre le principe de
subsidiarité en place pour en revanche
la précédente conférence de territoire
souvenez vous elle a été décidée on nous
a dit voilà on va supprimer la taxe
d'habitation on sait très bien qu'on
sera jamais compenser à l'euro près à se
confirmer on fait le dispositif de
cahors qui fait que vous êtes sous
tutelle de l'état c'est l'état qui
emprunte pour son fonctionnement pour sa
masse salariale moi je viens du milieu
de l'entreprise vous pouvez pas faire ça
vous êtes en faillite dans une
collectivité on ne peut pas on applique
la règle d'or donc tout d'un coup vous
dis je vais contre un de vos dépenses
mais sait pas pourquoi alors qu'on en
prenne que pour l'investissement et puis
une fois qu'on vous a dit ça comme ça
allait on dit on va faire une conférence
des territoires mais vous devrez signer
des contrats de corps dont qui ne sont
en fait les honneurs puisque c'était
contrat était totalement déséquilibrée
c'est une des parties qui implose et ces
contrats qui limite c'est pas des
contrats c'était un contre à la don
corleone ou quoi c'est à dire qu'il ya
une des parties qui qui qui qui vous dit
si tu ne signe pas on va pénaliser bon
voilà
politique oui après christian estrosi
vers falco remue renaud muselier a
apporté son soutien à emmanuel macron
est ce que vous sentez pas un petit peu
seul en paca
non parce que moi je me sens bien des
bougies avec mes convictions ce qui est
déjà pas mal et donc parfois vous savez
au mieux être seule est bien avec
soi-même que mal accompagné et en
l'occurrence non on peut en dans les
alpes-maritimes qui est le département
que je connais le mieux je crois que
c'est ce qui soutient emmanuel macron
qui sont plus isolés sire que vous
regardez jean leonetti qui ciotti et
lionnel luca michèle tabarot jérôme
viaud enfin tous les élus pardonnez moi
que ce que je ne cite pas me pardonne
mais on est bien dans nos convictions
c'est ce que les noms que vous citez ont
fait des choix ils ont ferons d'autres à
l'avenir je joue
je prends le pari ici
est en tout cas c'était pas une surprise
oui
mais une trêve de présenter votre compte
at elle est en chute libre dans les
sondages
est ce que vous craignez une
idéalisation de valérie pécresse
aujourd'hui dur
non ce que ce que ce que je crains c'est
qu'on est une une fausse élections
présidentielles alors qu'onesta aux
sélections pour des raisons de
circonstance qui sont pas de la faute de
quiconque enfin j ai vu qu vide et la
guerre en ukraine et l'organisation de
l'actualité aujourd'hui fait qu' on est
sur deux sur l'actualité monomaniaque
emmanuel macron qui refusent de débattre
je pense qu'ils gagneraient à débattre
en plus je pense qu'il le fait plutôt
bien donc qu'ils soient pas venir je ne
comprends pas je gens parlaient même
avec des élus qui sont proches de lui
parce que lmfao on a on a beaucoup de
maquereaux nistos 6 1 qui sont dans nos
instances et une personne ne le
comprenait en réalité
emmanuel macron instrumentalise les
circonstances mais il fait de la
politique fait de la tactique mais pour
en revenir à valérie pécresse c'est à
cause des circonstances de la guerre en
ukraine du coc vide qu'elle est
aujourd'hui à ce niveau dans les
sondages c'est ce qui a eu des erreurs
qui ont il ya certainement eu des
erreurs on off mais moi je la soutiens
ardemment parce que je la verrais que
presque à ce que je connais c'est
quelqu'un de qui a du caractère qui fait
les choses vraiment elle l'a montré non
partout où elle est passée elle a des
résultats
sa campagne je pense qu'il ya eu ce
meeting du zénith ou la forme était
était mauvaise et
par exemple
est-ce que c'est là valérie pécresse que
vous connaissez écoutez ça fait quand
même longtemps qu'elle est qu'elle est
cohérente sur un projet qui consiste à
dire comment en oxygène l'économie et
elle essaie d'apporter des propositions
c'est la seule qui parle d' optimisation
d'appareils d'état qui parle de
décentralisation sérieusement qui parle
de remettre les fonctionnaires là où ils
sont utiles sur le régalien et diminuer
là où ils servent à rien c'est la seule
qui possède que c'est que l'emporter
déjà que françois fillon d'ailleurs sur
l'immigration est depuis longtemps elle
a montré c'est une femme qui vit dans
son histoire ses actionnaires
elle est capable de rassembler des
personnes de toutes origines mais sur
l'immigration l'a toujours été ferme
elle a été sur le burqini elle était
comme d'autres comme moi très ferme donc
non elle est cohérente mais ses séides
ya eu 7 cette difficulté mais s'est pas
pliée enfin moi moi je suis navré mais l
affaire elle a très bien parlé des
collectivités territoriales on sait que
les choses se font très vite aujourd'hui
vous comprenez moi je suis engagé je la
soutiens on est près de l'échéance dont
je vais pas commenter les sondages je
suis dans le combat si vous voulez mais
quand gérard larcher dit que si ya pas
de campagne ce qu'elle qu'à l'heure
actuelle la question de la légitimité du
gagnant se posera vous partager ça mais
oui mais oui parce que le
évidemment tout à l'heure je parlais du
désastre du commerce extérieur qui est
le révélateur de la perte de
compétitivité de l'économie on peut me
sortir tous les baratins qu'on veut nous
sortir trois licorne 10 start up la
réalité c'est qu'on perd des parts de
marché le déficit public il faudra le
rembourser le quoi qu'il en coûte qui
était nécessaire à un moment donné est
devenue une spirale de clientélisme et
de distribution d'argent que l'état ne
possède pas la corse le régalien ce sont
des bombes à retardement le aujourd'hui
l'exécutif sacrifie l'avenir du pays et
le futur proche pour l'immédiate
électorale donc avec en plus on risque
d'avoir une abstention élevée eu un
débat qui ne se cristallise pas donc on
aura un problème de légitimité et moment
le vrai le vrai problème qui devrait
tous nous mobiliser c'est là tony
civique c'est l'abstention qui vous
concernent aussi localement et qui
passent par ce mélange de sentiments
d'impuissance public et d'historisation
de l'actualité c'est un problème
fondamental de la démocratie est malade
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
[Musique]